breaking news out of CES 2014 folks
PlayStation now is a thing I'm Chris
waters here with Sean McGinnis talk
about PlayStation now Sony's making good
on their promise to stream old
PlayStation games yeah
few years ago they bought Gaikai for
about three hundred and eighty million
dollars Gaikai obviously a streaming
game service that was competing with on
live at the time and everybody's been
wondering since then what are they gonna
do for PlayStation game what does Sony
got why did they get them they've been
hiding them away until last February
they mentioned streaming old games in
the PlayStation catalog there's sort of
a way to cover they're backwards
compatibility and here it is PlayStation
3 games PlayStation 2 games and
PlayStation 1 games streamable through
PlayStation now to the PlayStation 4 and
the PlayStation 3 to start then the
PlayStation Vita sony bravia tvs
manufactured in 2014 for the newest
models and then later on
internet-connected devices presumably
some kind of tablets mobiles at cetera
right and this is different from what
the retro games available on ps3 and
Vita which uses emulation to play PSone
classics obviously PlayStation 4 doesn't
do PSone classics that whole back
catalogue is gone and so this is the
Sony's way of sort of reviving it and
adding the ps2 and ps3 games as well
which is a nice addition it's nice that
we're gonna get to play that back
catalogue but unlike the classics which
you can purchase outright from the
PlayStation Store PlayStation now is
looking to be only a renting service so
far they've announced two ways you can
get it
renting on a title by title basis or
renting on a subscription basis that
gives you access to an unspecified
number of games in their catalogue yeah
and they're not announcing any firm
pricing details at the moment and the
other thing they're not talking about is
whether or not there's any integration
with this service and PlayStation Plus
which leads us to believe that it's not
a part of PlayStation Plus because
because if it was you better believe
they would be announcing that to the
high heavens because any reason for Sony
to sell more PlayStation Plus
subscriptions they want to jump on right
away they'd love to mention their
PlayStation Plus it's a good service but
seemingly no connection between
PlayStation Plus and PlayStation now as
of yet
one feature that does the both that both
share is cross save so when you're
playing a title through PlayStation now
on your Vita then you go to play it on
your bravia TV or your PlayStation 3 or
4 your save is going to continue across
all of those which is a nice little bit
of continuity and also worth mentioning
the Vita seems it's only going to be
Wi-Fi streaming so anyone 3g ended up on
their Vita but no word yet on what
titles will be available for PS now at
launch and no hard launch dates yet but
they do have some stuff on the horizon
yes sony is hoping to get this service
launched in the US by the end of summer
2014 and they are planning on a closed
beta later this month however there are
some caveats there yeah this stuff is us
only and sony hasn't mentioned any other
territories and in the past they've
discussed the difficulties of doing this
kind of streaming service to regions
without a lot of broadband coverage
which is a bunch of the world and also a
bunch of the u.s. so I guess we're gonna
see what kind of requirements it's gonna
take and you know where what territories
are gonna have in mind hopefully more
announcements on that as the year
progresses and speaking of further
announcements Sony did have a bit more
information at the CES press conference
turns out they sold 4.2 million
PlayStation 4 units which is pretty good
so far especially considering the
competition 3.0 million Xbox one sold so
in the units sold it looks like Sony is
doing quite well for themselves and I
wouldn't wonder if PS now makes things a
little more attractive for them yeah I
mean that and the hundred dollar price
difference you're kind of seeing in the
math right now absolutely for more from
these press conferences from CES 2014
stay tuned to game spot and follow us on
twitter at games bot I'm Chris waters
for Sean McGinnis saying thanks for
watching we'll see you soon